la passion de de de la fum maison j'ai
j'ai cru comprendre que vous avvez vu
très jeune vers 17 18 ans ouais ouais
ouais on a commencé à faire des beaux
produits avec des avec mon frère et des
amis ouais dans le jardin familial dont
du poisson fumé mais aussi du magré fumé
toutes ces belles choses vous avez
l'idée de ça parce qu'on a toujours bien
aimé manger voilà on a empêché un petit
peu donc voilà
c'est repas familiaux et entre amis on a
évolué on a développé des techniques euh
voilà on sit euh moi je me suis ça me
plaisait beaucoup je me suis un peu
spécialisé là-dessus j'ai fait
totalement autre chose d'autres études
euh voilà et d'autres métiers auparavant
et donc c'est une reconversion pas seul
on verra tout à l'heure qu'il il y a des
il y a des trajectoires très
intéressantes parmi vous euh c'est ça et
puis après vous avez rencontré un
spécialiste de la fum maison qui en
Normandie je crois ouais tout à fait
ouais ouais à Grandville euh qui m'a
voilà qui m'a qui m'a éclairé sur pas
mal de sujets
[Musique]
notamment technique je venais pas du
milieu de l'agroalimentaire donc donc
j'ai pu voir un petit peu de l'Intérieur
comment ça se
passait et ensuite voilà des passages
chez des aringis pour découverir le
métier en laboratoire laboratoire de
poissonnier on va
dire globalement et puis après il a
fallu se lancer et as on arrive à 2017
là oui c'est ça exactement il y a pas
d'école de d'artisans fumeur donc c'est
c'est des choses que je connaissais
j'avais pu voir
et puis beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup ou il
a pas d'école oui d'écoes non ça
n'existe pas près de de de de
spécialistes
ou c'est ça c'est des alors moi
je je suis souvent contacté
effectivement par des gens qui veulent
se lancer donc après on a rien à à caché
hein c'est relativement simple la fuma
maison de poisson mais il faut bien le
faire voilà pour que ça soit bon voilà
c'est avoir des bons produits à la base
ce qui est le cas pour beaucoup de
beaucoup de métiers et tout le monde
reconnaît que vous le faites
exceptionnellement donc je vous laisse
juger al 2017 vous installez à jou en
Josas jou en Josas ououais tout à fait
donc c'était mon fief a votre
laboratoire et puis il y a un point de
vente he ouais ouais un petit accueil le
but initialement c'était de montrer aux
gens que tout était bien fait chez nous
donc c'est un laboratoire qui est ouvert
sur un petit accueil donc quand les gens
viennent récupérer des des produits ils
voient clairement le fumoir la salle de
travail derrière euh on est complètement
transparent voilà on a aussi un point de
vente sur un
vousêtes au marché de de versaill le
weekend enfin ouais vendredi et dimanche
matin ouais pour toucher le plus grand
nombre de de personnes voilà et euh mais
tout en voilà on est sur un nous sur une
zone de une zone de chalandise pardon
qui est très restreinte euh voilà nos
clients ils sont juste autour de chez
nous donc on est vraiment au cœur de
notre territoire entre guillemets zone
de chalandise et c'était l'objectif
initialement on est on a des clients du
coin du coin voilà et vous avez aussi un
site j'ai vu ça marche très bien parce
que même les les commandes pour Noël
c'est un peu tard ouais ouais ouais Noël
c'est gentil d'êt venu parce que grand
plaisir un plaisir mais on peut on peut
commander tout le reste de l'année ouais
ouais ouais sur les fêtes on est sur une
activité qui est très très saisonnière
en particulier sur le sur le saumon fumé
ce qui reste saumon fumé euh alors pas
n'importe quel saum alors c'est du
saumon d'élevage hein ouais alors on est
on reste sur du saumon d'élevage on fait
de la truite aussi on est reste s de de
la truite d'élevage on a pris le parti
de partir de proposer d'autres poissons
sauvages euh
donc on est sur une base que les gens
aiment de la truite du saumon et on on
veut proposer d'autres produits pour
faire découvrir aux gens aussi d'autres
poissons fumés de pêche de pêche Coti
des poissons qui sont pas habituellement
consommés en fumison en fuma maison oui
c'est qu'on trouve chez vous ouais ouais
donc on va avoir je vous ai ramené VO
des sardines fumées du fléant de
l'iglefin on fait du mulet noir fumé qui
est pas un poisson qui est très mise en
valeur et qui est absolument délicieux
du bar il y a beaucoup de poules pens en
ce moment en Bretagne on va faire du
poupe fumé à partir de l'année prochaine
ah génial voilà on teste on teste
beaucoup de beaucoup oui ça parce que
c'est vrai que quand on parle poisson
fumé on pense tout suite au CE
évidemment alors ça va être le grand
must évidemment pour pour les les v
d'Écosse d'Irlande on est ouais sur sur
mer j'ai vu ouais alors il y a eu en ce
moment il y avait deux élevages français
qui éta à isini à Cherbourg ou il y a
voilà donc on a travaillé on a travaillé
avec les deux c'est un peu plus
compliqué en ce moment on espère pouvoir
retravailler avec un petit peu dans
votre avec charbour voilà les bêtes en
train de travailler voilà en tout cas
sur sur les poissons sur le saumon les
beaux produits d'élevage les beaux
poissons d'élevage viennent de d'Écosse
d'Irlande c'est des produits qui sont
labellisés oui donc on est sur une
qualité respectée sur un cahier des
charges au niveau de l'élevage qui est
aussi respecté qui est très clair que
tout le monde peut consulter donc on
sait ce qu'on comment s élevé ce qu'on
va Mang exactement il y a de la
transparence transparence aussi au
niveau des élevages sur C ça c'est bien
c'est c'est c'est un plus VO c'est très
important aujourd'hui savoir d'où vient
le produit comment il a été traité alors
vous nous avez apporté voil tout à fait
donc on a effectivement donc voilà les
saumons fumés qu' qu'on tranche
également on est sur sur du saumon on va
mettre une bonne semaine à le préparer
du saumon fumé ce qui est plutôt très
long comme cycle pour pour la fumaison
de poisson c'est une semaine à partir du
moment où vous partez du saumon qui vous
arrive je récupère je récupère partir
moment je vais lever les filets donc le
Fage la salaison avec un sel de mer d'
euh qui vient de de Guerand on va avoir
une fumaison à la ficelle donc avec des
poissons qui sont suspendus dans le
fumoir et une étape qui est très
importante c'est un affinage une
maturation en chambre d'affinage donc où
les poissons vont passer 4 5 6 jours
alors je vous dis 4 5 6 ça dépend de de
pas mal beaucoup de paramètres c'est
pour ça qu'on est artisan parce qu'on a
plein de de paramètres à gérer euh qui
sont jamais les mêmes donc on va les
voir tous les jours les poissons c'est
pas c'est pas on sait celui-là c'est 6
jours celui-là c'est 4 jours hein c'est
il faut regarder il faut il faut
surveiller il fautou tau de gras euh la
météo à l'extérieur enfin beaucoup
beaucoup de paramètres à qu'on peut pas
forcément maîtriser et donc on doit on
doit faire avec voilà euh vous
m'exliquez qu'il avait le fumage il y a
aussi le séchage alors le séchage ouais
l'affinage de séchage on va perdre
beaucoup on va faire sortir beaucoup
d'eau des produits pour concentrer le
goût d'accord euh pour éviter de trop
saler nos produits euh pour garder un
vrai un vrai goût euh le vrai goût du
des poissons qu'on va qu'on va
travailler euh et puis éviter surtout
cette saturation en selle qui est un peu
la PL dans la PL en principe dans quand
on achète dans les grand surface par
exemple enfin parfois c'est c'est très
salé c'est hein c'est vrai ouais ouais
ou beaucoup de saturationou pourquoi
parce que ça conserve non c'est ça c'est
la conservation qui on va avoir des gros
gros délis de conservation et ça évite
de faire sécher les poissons en fait ah
oui ah d'accord moi je perds je perd
entre 15 et 20 % du point de mes de mes
filets et oui il faut accepter ça et il
faut il faut l'accepter moi j'accepte
mais voilà oui mais oui toutes les il y
a des voilà industrie voilà qui c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est c'est
toujours mieux si on peut d'aller bchz
un artisan comme comme hriic
hein alors donc vous avez là il y avait
le saumon fumé le saumon fumé donc fait
de la truite fumé donc ça trum c'est un
copain MOS cher coup un petit peu moins
cher au kilo qui est d'une qualité
vraiment exceptionnelle elle est
délicieuse elle est vraiment très très
bonne c'est beaucoup moins gras alors
c'est pareil ça dépend d'où ça vient moi
je viens toujours je travaille toujours
avec le même pisculteur qui est en Haute
Normandie qui fait des super poissons
euh voilà et puis après vous avez les
prenez-les peut-être comme ça on les
verra m voilà on est ver où non non B
devant vous devant vous voilàès bien
comme ça donc les pavet de Semon fumé
pav de voilà bon c'est pareil on fait
des tranches des tranches aussi tout ça
c'est fait au couteau donc pour avoir
des tranches régulières c'est important
aussi euh et puis donc les produits je
vous ai apporté d'autres produits là de
de pêche oui alors il y a pas que le
saumon voilà exact il y a plein d'autres
choses euh vous avez de là mon préféré
c'est la sardine fumée donc c'est des
pêches françaises g c'est les mêmes
technique que sur du saumon que sur de
la truite c'est de la salaison de la
fumaison et et de l'affinage al c'est
vraiment très spécifique pour chaque
type de poisson pour chaque poisson euh
voilà ça sur une tartine de pain beé
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique oui ça
c'est vrai que oui on peut dire voilà au
gens qui nous qui nous regardent c'est
très bien le saumon c'est fort bien mais
voilà
il y a d'autres choses il y a pas il y a
pas que le saumon dans la vie ouais
ouais bah le voilà même si c'est le
produit phare et ouais c'est un produit
phare les gens adorent adorent ce
produit donc on le fait la sardine c'est
formidable non c'est exceptionnel la
sardine ouais hein puis on fait du du
macro aussi qui est voilà qui est aussi
très très bon alors qui sont aussi fa
faut dire des coups un peu moins
exactement VO on est sur des poissons
bien moins
chers donc on arrive à avoir par rapport
au prix d'un saumon fumé à être
pratiquement à la moitié du prix de oui
du saumon fumé c'est plein plein plein
de bonnes choses euh de plein d'omégga
différents euh et puis ça varie enfin et
puis euh voilà on on va au lieu de voilà
de se contenter du du cabillot sur du
poisson cuit en cuisson et sur du saumon
en poisson fumé mais il y a plein
d'autres choses y a plein d'autres
choses voilà on comment dire on va la
pression va pas être sur un seul poisson
on va aller travailler sur plein
d'autres poissons il y a plein d'autres
poissons qui sont euh qui sont très bons
euh le macro la sardine euh vous avez le
mulet noir je parlais du mulet noir qui
une image qui est chez les cuisiniers
qui est très bonne maisou che le monieur
tout le
monde c'est c'est un poisson qui est
absolument merveilleux en cuisson mais
en fumaison aussi
euh voilà il a
énormément ntendu il faut aller chez
vous quoi aller chez vous sur votre site
évidemment ou oui ben venir découvrir
tout ça et puis passer on a ouvert toute
l'année on mange du poisson fumé à toute
la oui ça il y y a évidemment on mange
pour les fes mais c'est vrai que ça
c'est quand j'étais quand j'étais enfant
on mangait assez peu aujourd'hui ça
s'est quand même répandu c'est vrai hein
le même le saent fumé quoi peut-être
malheureusement d'ailleurs oui oui c'est
malheureusement mais mais c'est un vrai
sujet peut-être que voilà il faut c'est
mieux je pense que c'est toujours mieux
d'aller chez un
artisan que que voilà que dans une
grande surface mais mais moins mais
moins mais mieux
quoi tout à l'heure c'est ça ouais tout
à fait donc c'est ça fumerie du coin
c'est ça fumerie du coin c'est à jou en
Josas et puis le vendredi le dimanche
sur le sur le marché de versaill et puis
il y a le site si fait fumerie du coin
on trouve votre votre site exactement
avec toutes les informations vous êtes
un fur
heureux et en bonne
senté êes un fumeur actif
exactement